vestigios de la guerra fría con Cuba en
el centro de la polémica nuevamente a
flote de acuerdo con la publicación de
Wall Street journal que cita de manera
anónima a los funcionarios de
inteligencia estadounidenses china
habría alcanzado un acuerdo con Cuba
para instalar una base en la isla
caribeña a cambio del pago de millones
de dólares que le permitiría espiar a
los estadounidenses a 90 millas de las
cosas de Florida al sureste del país el
pentágono restó importancia a la
publicación calificándola como inexacta
puedo decirles con base a la información
que tenemos que eso no es Exacto que no
estamos al tanto de que China y Cuba
desarrolle en algún tipo de estación de
espionaje y type Station el pacto
permitiría Beijing captar señales de
inteligencia en partes del sureste de
Estados Unidos hogar de instalaciones
militares e importantes industrias al
tiempo que para Cuba Se presenta como un
bálsamo en medio de la crisis económica
que padece el gobierno de La Isla
rechazó el informe y acusó que forma
parte de un plan para justificar el
recrudecimiento del embargo nuestro país
es firmante de la declaración de América
Latina y del Caribe como zona de paz
suscrita en la Habana en enero de 2014
en virtud de ella rechazamos toda
presencia militar foránea en América
Latina y el Caribe incluida la de
numerosas bases y efectivos militares de
los Estados Unidos la noticia tensa aún
más las relaciones entre Washington y la
Habana al tiempo que incrementa los
temores de un sector en Estados Unidos
por la expansión de china en América
Latina y el Caribe